the u.s is imposing new economic
sanctions to punish russia for the
attack on ukraine president biden calls
the measures unprecedented in their
strength others believe though they just
do not go far enough nancy cordes is at
the white house with more on that part
of the story nancy good morning to you
good morning gail yeah the economic
consequences for russia are really
piling up it isn't just the u.s the eu
the uk canada australia japan all
slapping new sanctions on russia and as
a result the russian stock market has
lost nearly 50 percent of its value just
in the past week and many of these
sanctions haven't even taken effect yet
as anti-putin protests popped up from
paris to london to berlin to new york
the white house targeted five major
russian banks announcing plans to cut
them off from the u.s financial system
putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences the u.s will also halt all
its high-tech exports to russia
including the computer chips critical to
russia's military and aerospace industry
leaders from around the world announced
similar steps we are imposing further
severe sanctions he will never be able
to cleanse the blood of ukraine from his
hands but president biden stopped short
of sanctioning putin's own assets and to
the disappointment of some lawmakers he
did not move to block russia from swift
a global payment system crucial to
international trade whatever we can do
to escalate that price i think will
improve the chances of bringing this
conflict to an end
rather than seeing it prolong for years
please save ukrainian men women and
children in an emotional interview with
cbs news a member of the ukrainian
parliament urged the world to cut russia
off from swift
russia from sweden i beg you
please save our people
and other dozens of people and maybe
hundreds of people might be murdered
tonight but president biden said some
european allies who rely on russia for
oil and gas aren't ready to take that
step the sanctions we've imposed exceed
swift the sanctions we opposed exceed
anything that's ever been done let's
have a conversation in another month or
so to see if they're working
the problem of course is that there's no
telling how much damage russia can do
in one month's time president biden is
set to hold an extraordinary virtual
summit this morning with nato leaders as
they discuss the security situation in
and around ukraine nate nancy thank you